hi everyone welcome back I'm Sam from
Pixie loop and today we're going to be
talking about having two different
lipstick colors in your makeup bag and
how it can work really well depending on
your mood these ones are the Kate
lasting finish lipsticks I have the
nudes and then I have a bunch of brights
as well now I will often wear a new
during the day sometimes I'll wear a
nude in the evening with a smoky eye but
if I've got a business meeting during
the day I'm always going to go for a
read because I really mean business I'm
going to show you how to do this easy
brown smokey eye which works great with
a nude lip any nude and it works great
with the red lip too and I'm going to be
showing you this black smokey eye there
works with news and it also looks
awesome with bright colors I've got the
Rimmel scandaleyes this is an eyeshadow
stick and I absolutely love these
they're so easy to use the color I'm
using is bluffing and I'm just putting
this all over my eyelid like that just
drawing it over this makes it super
super quick in the morning and then I'll
just rub a brush along the edge just to
blend that in these are waterproof as
well so they set super fast and they're
going to stay all day so buff that all
over the lid now I'm switching to
magnifies and this is a double-ended
product so on the end here we've got an
eye shadow and then we've got a liner on
this end we're going to use the bronze
just to really bronze this up this is
going just at the lash line and then
just blend that in these go on so easy
just blending this bronze into the
bluffing color that we already put on
there so we get a nice gradient going
upwards I'm taking a little bit of that
just under the eye as well now the
lovely thing about the way Kate where's
her makeup is that it's always a little
bit underdone so that means we don't
have to make it too polished for it to
look really cool so don't worry too much
if it's a bit kind of thrown on because
as long as we make our lipstick really
perfect and really neatly applied and
our skin it will look really awesome
trust me then I'm going to switch to the
other end and pop a little bit of that
just on the waterline and then straight
into mascara I've
up volume flash here and I'm using a
black give the wand a little bit of a
rock at the root of the lash and then a
flick out so you get masses of volume
next I have lasting finish one thousand
kisses this is in the color cappuccino
the lipstick is number forty eight from
the Kate lasting finishing nudes the
news come in a big array of colors
that's suitable for every skin tone and
you can see this is a very dark nude so
it's going to look completely nude on
someone with a darker skin I don't like
completely nude on me
I like a little bit of color so I'm
using this one the lasting finish
lipsticks are really comfortable to wear
they're going to give you high intensity
color for up to eight hours same with
the lip pencils I have worn this
lipstick really really sheer but I love
it I absolutely think it's so pretty and
so flattering so this is the makeup that
I would wear with a nude but it also
works really beautifully with the red so
let me change the lips thousand kisses
lip pencil in red dynamite
0:21 I absolutely love this red this is
0-1 it is identical to the lip pencil so
this is my failsafe easy brown smokey if
I'm in a rush I can get this on and it
looks great with a red it looks great
with the noodle it's great with most
lipstick colors which is brilliant
because there's so many in this
collection next I'm going to show you
something I'm going to use a black and
I'm going to show you something a little
bit more full on okay
Rimmel magnifies this one is back to
Black's one end is a waterproof sort of
charcoal eyeshadow and the other end is
a black kohl I'm going to start with the
eye shadow and we're going to put that
really close to the lash line then using
a brush I'm going to blend that I'm
blending it outwards rather than upwards
this is a long wear eye shadow and it's
transfer-resistant as well so that means
it's going to last all day next we're
going to flick to the cold end and we're
just going to put that along the
waterline then back in with our mascara
i'm actually using hide the blemish
concealer just under my eyes because i'm
very dark under my eyes on and every bit
of extra help and i'm just going to
blend that in as I was saying earlier it
doesn't really matter if you go a little
bit messy with the eyes as long as the
skin looks quite neat and the lips right
with these eyes I'm going to use termas
mm kisses pencil and number 43 from the
Kate news it's a lovely kind of peachy
nude then just a tiny little look all
together I'm going to take a little bit
of a Rimmel bronzer just run that
through here and pop a little of that
just on the cheeks this kind of black
smoky eye always makes me think of Kay
next I'm going to try it with a bright
lip next I'm taking spice lip pencil and
I'm going to mix that into this
beautiful vibrant coral this is number
37
and it also looks awesome with bright
corals like this so there's a couple of
my quickest makeup looks and I use these
ones the most frequently because who has
time these days you can mix and match
with any lip you like obviously they
work with everything thank you so much
for watching I hope you've enjoyed it
take care and I'll see you next time bye
bye